in einigen bundesländern gilt ab dieser
woche die optionale zweig regelung das
heißt veranstalter und auch gastronomen
haben freie hand zu entscheiden ob sie
nur geimpfte und gelesene einlassen
wollen also diese zweig oder ob sie 3g
machen und auch getestete reinlassen
wollen das auch im leben auch kinder und
jugendliche ab zwölf jahren sind in der
regel von den einschränkungen betroffen
da es für diese altersgruppen
mittlerweile ja auch ein impfangebot
gibt und uns zugeschaltet ist jetzt
professor andrew ullmann ist
infektiologe an der uniklinik würzburg
professor ullmann
können wir uns ja
hallo ich grüße sie wie sehen sie das
als infektiologe
also dass infektiologie sehe ich es ganz
eindeutig übrigens auch als politiker
das nur mit der impfung kommt können wir
dieser pandemie die globale stattfindet
herr werden das heißt nicht nur gerade
in deutschland nach vorne bringen
sondern auch weltweit das ist der
einzige weg die frage ist nur wie wir
diesen weg beschreiten wollen die wollen
wir die impfrate nach vorne bringen und
wir haben eigentlich an der sehr schöne
und gute impfrate aber wir sind noch
nicht am ziel wir brauchen noch eine
höhere impfraten um unser
gesundheitssystem zu schützen über der
weg dahin ist politisch sehr umstritten
ich halte nicht viel davon die menschen
indirekt zu zwingen zu einem impfung
sondern man muss die menschen die bisher
noch nicht geimpft sind klar aufklären
und auch ihre ängste und sorgen nehmen
weil da gibt es sehr viel unfug im netz
zu den impfstoffen und werden diese
aufklärung irgendwas ist auch natürlich
auch viel schwerer als nur druck
auszuüben umgesetzt werden würde dann
wäre es natürlich viel einfacher und was
jetzt noch in berlin passiert wo kinder
ausgeschlossen werden von
veranstaltungen halte ich politisch für
schäbig dann immerhin erst seit genau
heute vor vier wochen hat die ständige
impfkommission die impfungen für kinder
ab zwölf jahren empfohlen und ich halte
diese art der politik für ein
fehlverhalten und auch ganz klar einen
weg in die falsche richtung
der rot rot grüne senat in berlin hat er
angekündigt da nochmal nachzujustieren
diesem fall haben sie angesprochen also
zweig auch ja gültig für kinder und
keine ausnahmen bisher für kinder da
möchte man nachschärfen vor allem damit
familie nicht vor restaurants stehen und
die kinder dürfen nicht mit rein vor
allem die unter zwölf die gar nicht erst
geimpft werden dürfen wie will man
dieses problem in den griff bekommen
konnte man auch überhaupt auf die idee
kommen kinder da so auszugrenzen gerade
die die in dieser pandemie so sehr
gelitten haben
also wie man auf diese idee gekommen ist
kann ich nur schwer nachvollziehen auch
für die familien ist das ein unding was
da geschehen ist es ein schlag ins
gesicht all dieser familie und der
kinder wir sind auch zum teil sehr
schlecht vorbereitet auf die aufs
nächste schuljahr mit luft
reinigungsgeräten in den schulen die zum
größten teil ja noch fehlen hier haben
wir eine gruppe vernachlässigt sträflich
vernachlässigt und zwar die kinder und
die familien ich erinner nur ein home
office und homeschooling welche
doppelbelastung existiert haben und in
der wissenschaft herrschte relative
einmütigkeit das ob man jetzt geimpft
getestet oder auch frisch genesen ist
dass das risiko einer infektion
gering ist wenn natürlich die tester
natürlich negativ ausgefallen ist und
das sollte man einfach immer wieder mal
berücksichtigen deswegen ist es auch gut
dass das der senat in berlin nachgedacht
hat und ein wenig korrigiert hat das
jetzt die kinder unter zwölf jahren
zwischen sechs und zwölf jahren ich das
richtig wahrgenommen habe die dann
negativ getestet sein sollten das ist
also eine dreijährige zumindest unter
zwölf jahren aber auch ich bleibe dabei
auch die kinder und jugendlichen ab
zwölf bis 18 jahren sind vernachlässigt
weil auch hier sollte die 3g regel
weiter geld zu verschaffen denn die
impfungen sind noch gar nicht
abgeschlossen können auch gar nicht
abgeschlossen sein
sie haben es gesagt es soll kein in
direkter druck gemacht werden im druck
gemacht werden aber es klappt ja
offenbar so nicht mit der
impfbereitschaft die zahl stagniert seit
wochen bei uns
etwas über 60 prozent somit 60 prozent
wie soll man die anderen 35 denn dann
überhaupt noch erreichen
ein kleines beispiel möchte ich hier
gerne aus meiner heimatstadt würzburg
bringen ich erlebe jetzt gerade den
wahlkampf wir sind überall in den
verschiedenen parteien unterwegs an den
marktplätzen in den fußgängerzonen und
immer wieder gibt es auch menschen auch
bei mir am stand die über die impfung
sprechen und mich auch speziell
ansprechen als infektiologe und ich
frage mich tatsächlich warum haben wir
in unserer stadt die querdenker als
infostand vorhanden aber nicht vom
gesundheitsamt hier erwarte ich mehr
initiativen auch von den kommunen
aufklärung zu betreiben und idealerweise
meinetwegen noch einen kleinen infos
dazu zu stellen dass die leute gleich
geimpft werden ein parteikollege von mir
hat gerade erst am wochenende in ost
franken eine einer feier gehabt wo auch
da menschen geimpft worden sind das sind
25 menschen geimpft worden hier müssen
wir die impfung zu den menschen bringen
ich weiß dass es sehr mühselig ist aber
das ist der weg um aus dieser pandemie
krise herauszukommen professor immer an
vielen dank für ihre informationen ich
danke ihnen
[Musik]